the entire field of AI is divided on one
philosophical question what is thought
do you know what side you're on and are
you sure you understand the full 30-year
history of Chachi BT I just released a
video which outlines the whole story
starting in 1986 with a little Circuit
of 12 neurons wired together trained to
guess the next letter in a sequence not
only did it learn the pattern in general
but it could generate it by looping back
on itself 5 years later someone tried
this with a slightly bigger Network
trained on sentences and it seemed to
learn the word semantically
then we went on to train larger networks
using all of Wikipedia and they could
answer general questions even questions
they were not trained on eventually we
trained a network almost as big as our
minds on predicting the next word on the
whole internet the results stunned
researchers everything that I used to
believe was the case is being overturned
most critically is its ability to learn
new things even after training is
finished that changed everything see my
full video in the description